und ich werde jetzt ehrlich schwarze
eine der
Initiatoren hier direkt begrüßen an der
Veranstaltung Frau Schwarzer danke dass
Sie hier sind
Frau Schwarzer Ausstand für den Frieden
heißt ihre Veranstaltung Ausstand das
klingt so ein bisschen nach
volksausstatt aber wir haben doch eine
Demokratie da brauchen wir doch keinen
Volksaufstand
politischen Klasse und dem Volk wir alle
Umfragen und diese wunderbare friedliche
Veranstaltung sagen uns dass die
Mehrheit der Menschen endlich
Verhandlungen für den Frieden will und
dass sie gegen immer weitere Aufrüstung
ist und da wir sehen heute dass wir sehr
viele sind die das wünschen
was ich nicht ganz verstehe ist der
friedensbegriff eigentlich heißt es auch
immer Frieden ist doch also das ist
Frieden jetzt mit einmal das Recht der
stärkeren weil sie wollen ja einen
waffenstopp und das würde ja bedeuten
dass die Ukraine zusammenbrechen würde
schon wieder Gottes Willen wir fordern
das endlich
verhandelt wird und bevor man verhandeln
kann muss man sagen wir schön
miteinander reden da gibt es dann
erstmal einen
Waffenstillstand und dann gibt es
Gespräche und dann gibt es Kompromisse
und dann hofft man das endlich ein Ende
ist mit dem Sterben und wieder
Zerstörung aber wissen Sie ich finde das
nicht den Moment ich habe in den letzten
Wochen so viel diskutiert und gucken Sie
sich das doch einfach mal an
gucken sich die FIFA der Welt das
Mikrofon müssen sie mir in der Hand
schon lassen Frau Schwarzer Frau
Schwarzer aber wenn man noch mal sie
sind ja Feministin das haben sie auch
eben noch mal in ihrer Rede betont und
ist es ja so wir haben von vielen
geheultaten in diesem Krieg gehört die
ukrainischen Frauen sind vergewaltigt
worden ob es systematisch ist das wird
sicherlich noch geklärt werden müssen
Sie sich nicht auch für das ukrainische
Volk einsetzen das ja so schwer von der
russischen Invasion getroffen wurde
wovon reden Sie Herr Kollege wer setzt
sich mehr als wir hier für das
ukrainische Volk ein wissen sie Waffen
töten und wir möchten das nicht nein der
Ukraine gestorben wird im ersten Jahr
sind schon 250.000 Menschen dort
gestorben reden wir nicht von der
vergewaltigten Frauen reden wir nicht
von den traumatisierten Kindern und
inzwischen nach einem Jahr Krieg wird
uns gesagt dieser Krieg ist militärisch
ist nicht zu gewinnen man muss
verhandeln das Sagen vor allem die die
kenntnisreichen Militärs und nun ist von
einem abnutzungskrieg die Rede man
stelle sich mal dieses Unwort des Jahres
vor abnutzungskrieg ja also Menschen
werden abgenutzt aber noch mal was ich
was ich ein bisschen heute auch in den
Reden vermisst habe und vielleicht
können sie es aber jetzt hier auch noch
mal ganz klar sagen sie sehen schon den
aggress so Russland und sie fordern auch
würden sie damit übereinstimmen mit der
UN-Konvention die ja vorgestern
verabschiedet wurde Russland muss sich
komplett zurückziehen aus dem besetzen
selbstverständlich Russland muss ich
natürlich russland ist der Adresse der
brutale Aggressor und Russland
sich ausstellen am 24 Februar besetzen
Gebieten zurückziehen das ist doch
selbstverständlich und die Ukraine muss
dafür eine Garantie des Westens bekommen
eine Sicherheitsgarantie das ist klar
das sind die Basics ja aber warum reden
wir nicht jetzt darüber und erst in drei
Jahren wenn doch eine Millionen Menschen
gestorben ist es ist einfach skandalös
dieser Krieg sie haben noch mal gesagt
sie müssen nicht beweisen dass sie gegen
Rechts sind das war noch mal ich war
noch mal eine ja ihrer ganz klaren
Äußerung trotzdem muss man ja sagen dass
man die fest dass sie so ausgerufen
haben man die Aufstand für den Frieden
das ist unterzeichnet worden von vielen
rechten unter anderem
er ist ja der AFD ehrlich drehen Sie
sich doch mal um gucken sich die
Menschen an dass man nicht fest ist von
600 000 Menschen unterzeichnet worden
darunter ist ein und hier können Sie mal
fragen gucken sich mal hier die
Rechtsradikalen an die hier stehen ja
die angeblich dass man eine
festunterzeichnet haben das ist das Volk
wir sind es leid und wir wollen nicht
sie vermehrt werden und als recht
abgestempelt werden wenn wir Frieden
fordern es gibt ja nichts was linker ist
als Frieden sie haben noch mal gesagt
das fand ich auch eine ganz interessante
Bemerkung sie haben gesagt sie sind das
Volk und sie würden mehr sozusagen zu
sagen haben als sie gewählten
Volksvertreter aber das würde ja die
Demokratie ein bisschen hier bei uns
aushebeln aber wissen sie sowas nennt
man nennt man die sind vielleicht jung
dafür wenn ich das sagen darf sowas
nennt man außer parlamentarischen
Protest ich war mein Leben lang in der
außerparlamentarischen Politik also in
Bewegung ich bin in keiner Partei und es
ist ganz gut glaube ich wenn ein in
einer Demokratie das Volk auch eine
Stimme hat und auch sagen kann Moment da
macht ihr vielleicht einiges falsch hört
mal auf uns
es ist schwarzer herzlichen Dank für das
Interview